[Music]
it is the best-selling book in history
no volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted and its words sometimes
simple and sometimes mysterious should
always be studied carefully it is the
bible the word of god
welcome to bible answers live providing
accurate and practical answers to all
your bible questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the bible
resources mentioned in this broadcast
call 800-835-6747
once again that's 800-835-6747
now here's your host from amazing facts
international pastor doug batchelor
hello friends would you like to hear an
amazing fact
a 22 year old kenyan man was found alive
in the wheel well of a dutch cargo plane
that had traveled from johannesburg
south africa to the netherlands
police say on january 22 2022 the
stowaway whose identity was not released
was discovered hiding after the plane
touched down at the chippel airport in
amsterdam
the plane made a stop in nairobi which
is where it's believed the man climbed
into the front wheel well
officials say it is miraculous that he's
alive
records indicate the boeing 747 cargo
jack flew above 30 000 feet for most of
the 11 hour leg of the flight where the
air temperature can drop to more than 40
degrees below zero
the wheel wells on these aircraft have
no heat and they're unpressurized oxygen
levels would be thinner than the summit
of mount everest
police said the man who has applied for
asylum is doing well considering the
circumstances and he was taken to a
hospital you know friends it's amazing
the risks that people will take looking
for a better country
absolutely pastor it's a it's amazing
fact or amazing story this that this
this young man 22 was able to spend that
much time that high that cold in the
plane in the wheel well of the plane and
still survive unfortunately there are a
number of stories of people that tried
the same thing and did not survive that
seems to be the more common outcome so
really it almost seems like a miracle is
involved in preserving this man's life
yeah it's incredible they're still doing
some research you know into exactly what
happened but uh
i'm a pilot and i know once you get to
14 000 feet you're supposed to have
supplemental oxygen here he was at 30
000 feet for 11 hours
and
you know even the folks that climb mount
everest
they need oxygen at 28 000 feet
and and the temperature just
at least 40 degrees below zero and so
it's just incredible
and i'm looking forward to hearing more
about that story and how it ends but
it tells you about how they were
seeking a better country and the the
risks that a person would take makes me
think of that verse in the bible you
find in hebrews chapter 11
talking about the faithful
and it says for those who say such
things and this is verse 14 of hebrews
11 those who say such things declare
plainly that they seek a homeland
and truly if they had called to mind the
country from which they had come out
they would have had an opportunity to
return
but now they desire a better that is a
heavenly country
therefore god is not ashamed to be
called their god for he's prepared a
city for them
and the bible tells us that
the story of scripture is really people
trying to get from
the slavery of egypt to the promised
land or the captivity of babylon to the
promised land they're looking for that
bitter country
and this is the story of salvation god
is trying to save us from the captivity
and slavery of the devil
and take us to
the new jerusalem
you know pastor you look at an example
of folks who have gone through
incredible ordeals to try and find
freedom to get to a better land of
course this is one story you mentioned
but i'm sure there are many stories of
what people have risked
shouldn't we be
that determined and that committed to
seek that heavenly country that the
bible speaks of so much better than any
earthly country that anyone can have
well we do have a study guide that talks
about this heavenly country it's called
a colossal city in space and this is our
free offer this evening if you'd like to
receive this all you'll need to do is
call our resource phone number is
800-835-6747
and you can ask for offer number 115
that is a colossal city in space it's
all about heaven it's the home of the
redeemed it's that better country that
we read about in the book of hebrews so
we want to encourage you to take
advantage of that if you're outside of
north america you can go to the amazing
facts website just amazingfacts.org
and you'll be able to read that study
guide you can actually enroll in our
free online bible school and you can not
only see that lesson but all of the
lessons that we have in our amazing
facts series we'll pass it out before we
get to the phone lines let's start with
the word of prayer
dear father we thank you once again that
we have this opportunity to open up your
word and study and lord we always want
to make sure that we're seeking the holy
spirit to guide us in our study of your
word it's your book and we want to
rightfully understand it be with those
who are listening wherever they might be
and we ask this in jesus name amen amen
all right well we've got a number of
folks who are waiting online and again
good evening friends and welcome to
bible answers live now of course there's
people passing like listening to us on
the radio but we're also live streaming
this on facebook on your facebook
channel doug bachelor facebook as well
as amazing facts
we're also on youtube and we're on
amazingfactstv and uh good news tv
that's right and if people want to call
in we still have lines open if you're
calling the number is 800 god says
800-463-7297 with your bible questions
and still plenty of time to get your
question on tonight's program
all right our first call it tonight is
lawrence listening from oregon lawrence
welcome to the program
thank you
yeah how can we help you tonight
my question is i i have really uh
lots of health problems and i'm going to
some
really bad financial crisis i just want
to know
from the bible what will be the best way
to
look into it
and how to solve this financial problem
i'm going to probably it's not just me
around the world that you know their
situation but
i don't have enough knowledge you know
of how to find a guidance
and to achieve the financial
crisis uh that uh
i'm going through right now
yeah
well there are a lot of principles in
the bible that
talk about finances in fact i think
somebody said that
of the parables and the teachings of
jesus
are related to finances
and several of his parables where he the
the landowner gives out the different
talents to the different servants and he
talks about you know faithfully
investing
those things
and
you know of course these lessons are all
compared with the kingdom of god so the
first thing jesus tells us is to seek
first his kingdom
make his kingdom a priority and then it
says all the other things you need what
shall i eat what shall i drink what
shall i wear
the lord tells us don't worry
god doesn't want us to live in a state
of worry if we're faithful in the
following the principles he promises to
take care of us
and there's that verse that says
in psalms
i was once young and i'm now old and
have not seen god's people forsaken or
his seed begging bread
so
as far as specific financial advice
there are a lot of parables are proverbs
that give some advice on faithfulness
and diligence and investing and
even generosity um you know we have a
lesson that talks about uh bible
principles and finances that will direct
you to those many scriptures because we
can't share all of them right here yeah
the lesson is called in god we trust and
it lays out a number of biblical
principles dealing with stewardship and
finance and
what are the principles that we find in
the bible about managing our money so
we'll be happy to send this to anyone
who calls and asks the number for that
is 800-835-6747
and you can ask the study guide it's
called in god we trust and you'll be
blessed um by reading that lawrence or
anybody who's out there if you're
outside of north america you can also
read it by just going to our amazing
facts website just amazingfacts.org or
dot com
next quarter that we have is uh
sharon i guess or sharon listening from
texas
hi sharon welcome
yesterday
russ thank you thank you for having me
yeah um my question today is i'm reading
in the book of acts um actually in
chapter nine where saul who later became
paul
um
there it was the story is being
described what happened to him how he
fell and and um
and jesus was talking to him you know
asking him why are you persecuting me in
that when he gets when it gets to verse
it says and the men who journeyed with
him stood
speechless
hearing a voice
but seeing no one well that's just part
of it but then i went on first i was
continuing reading in acts and when i
got to chapter 22
and now it was saul himself who was
describing his experience that day and
all and when i got down
to
verse 9
it says and those who were this is him
speaking and those who were with me
indeed
saw light
and were afraid but they did not hear
the voice of him who spoke to me so what
i'm wanting to know is
in acts 9 7
they heard but saw nothing and then on
verse
chapter 22 9 then it says they saw but
they did not hear it's just total
seems like a country
yeah well keep in mind the good news is
the book of acts was written by the same
man so it's not like two different
authors disagreeing luke wrote both uh
accounts
uh and in the greek when you get to acts
chapter 22 the word here
is also similar to the word understand
so the way that uh i think you could
look at these two verses where it seems
like there's an apparent conflict one
time it says they heard a voice then it
says they didn't hear a voice
in acts chapter 22 it's really saying
they didn't understand the voice
but it's something like in john the
bible says that there was a voice that
says this is my beloved son and some
people heard the voice but they thought
it was thunder they didn't understand it
so evidently they heard a noise they
heard a voice but they didn't know what
it was saying
and that's why paul when sharing this
account or luke i should say sharing
this account in one place
he says yeah they heard a voice they
know that somebody spoke to him but when
you get to acts 22 it says they don't
know what the voice was saying to paul
only paul understood the voice of jesus
does that make sense
it does make sense it in that point
where you describe that but but then it
also talks about how the first one
didn't see anything but the second and
the second one they they did see it you
know is that the same thing well i think
they saw the light they saw the glory
but i think paul saw jesus
and they did it he was struck blind by
what he saw they obviously didn't see
the same thing the light did not blind
them but i think they saw some glory
appeared
so it's almost like they they got a
vision secondhand
you know they heard a noise they saw a
light paul's the one who really
understood the words and saw the face
okay but yeah good questions yeah thanks
so much sharon appreciate your question
all right we got uh diana listening from
washington diana welcome to the program
hi pastor thank you for having me
thank you so my question is um oh sorry
um my question is if my family does not
believe in the ten commandments or
they believe in them believed in them
but they don't believe that we are to
honor them today um says that allah
died with jesus and how would i witness
to them um over something that was
so
drilled into all of our heads for so
long yeah that's a challenge you know
and and i'm understanding you're saying
that uh they're they're christians is
that right
yes yes uh-huh yeah so it's it's
phenomenal to me that christians would
be saying
yeah we believe in jesus but we don't
need to keep the ten commandments
because
in reality i'll tell you what the issue
is
you could go to ninety percent of the
churches in north america and you could
preach on
uh commandments 1-3
and 5-10 and they would say amen
but when you preach on commandment 4
which is about the sabbath day they say
we're no longer under the law
now there is one church they don't like
when you talk about idolatry
uh a couple of churches maybe that don't
like that but otherwise most christians
have no problems with the law they all
believe don't commit adultery don't
steal don't kill don't dishonor god's
name
i know because i've preached in many of
these churches
but when they hear the sabbath truth and
then they realize that the seventh day
is saturday not sunday a lot of folks
start to get nervous and they say how do
we deal with this it's obviously part of
the ten commandments
and so they um they say well we're not
under the law and he said what about the
other commandments well they've been
reattached
and it's kind of like a person that has
one finger that's bothering them so they
cut off all ten
and then sew nine of them back on to try
to get rid of one
it just doesn't make sense and the
solution of course is keep all 10. that
was god's plan especially the one
commandment that begins with the word
remember
would not be the commandment you'd get
rid of
so now we have a book that talks about
does god's grace blot out the law and
we'll be happy to send that to anyone
who calls and asks the number to call is
800-835-6747
you can ask for the book it's called
does god's grace blot out the law and it
answers that question of you know under
the new covenant do we still need to
keep the ten commandments look at a
number of scriptures again the book is
called does god's grace blot out the law
and the number for that is 800-835-6747
and you just let the operator know that
you'd like that book thanks for your
call diane we've got doug listening in
arizona doug welcome to the program
hi you guys thank you for taking my call
yeah
and your question i uh have a question
from colossians i was talking to
somebody about the sabbath and
they referred to paul basically
saying that it didn't matter
well it says therefore do not let anyone
judge you by what you eat or drink
or with regard to the religious festival
a new moon celebration or a sabbath day
because
they think i'm crazy for honoring the
sabbath
and these are christian people as well
yeah well i if you read the way it reads
in the king james or the new king james
version it says so let no one judge you
in food or in drink or regarding a
festival or new moon or sabbath sin it's
plural and it's small s not capital s
the jews had several annual sabbaths
that were part of their ceremonial law
these things along with the sacrificing
of lambs and circumcision were all
nailed to the cross
and it talks about blotting out it's in
the earlier part of colossians chapter
2.
it says in verse 14 having wiped out or
abolished the handwriting
of requirements that was against us
the bible says moses wrote with his hand
the ceremonial laws
that would be a witness against them the
ceremonial laws is the law that was a
witness against them written by the hand
of moses
the ten commandments were written by the
finger of god in stone not parchment or
paper or leather you don't nail that to
a cross
so it's they're just totally misapplying
the see this the ceremonial sabbath came
after sin
the sabbath that's in the ten
commandments came before sin it was in
the garden of eden on the seventh day of
creation and so the idea that that
believers no longer need that day of
rest is really absurd when you think
about it now i've had two questions back
to back on this subject yeah while we
ought to offer our lesson on the sabbath
you know just to add to that like verse
17 i think is the key here where it says
which are a shadow of the things to come
but the substance is christ so when
you're looking at the ceremonial sabbath
they're a type of christ
and if we look at the context of the
book of colossians paul is dealing with
an issue where there were
jewish christians who were telling the
gentile believers or the gentile
christians are there to keep the
ceremonial law
and yet paul is saying no you don't have
to keep those ceremonial laws that were
a shadow but the substance is christ
he's not talking about the ten
commandments that's right
all right you know the book that we
offered a little earlier does god's
grace blot out the law actually covers
this as well so that's a great offer for
anyone wanting to learn more about that
the number to call is 800-835-6747
and you can also ask for our study guide
it's called written in stone it's about
the ten commandments
and again written in stone the number is
800-835-6747
we've got robert listening in new jersey
robert welcome to the program
uh good evening pastor good evening are
you able to hear me yeah hi pastor uh
doug and pastor john yeah my question is
okay my question is concerning
uh if christ and and going to the cross
now i think it might have been an
indicator some of these tell me in the
gospel of uh
matthew that had ev had everybody
accepted him and all his people
everybody and not foot against him if
everybody accepted that he was the
messiah that he would not have to go to
the cross i mean i mean that that was
more like a back-up complaint and then i
would this i had to find that but i know
the book of hebrews says he despised the
cross but i mean
others say that he had to go oh they say
that if everybody accepted it he might
not have had so i i want to find out
exactly
you know what what's the um what's the
truth on that all right well that's a
good question but keep in mind whenever
we ask a hypothetical question
it's hard to prove
because all you can do is you know
theorize
people say well if if eve ate the
forbidden fruit but adam didn't
what would have happened then would god
have just
got rid of even get adam a new wife or
would
he just have forgiven evil so if
everybody had accepted jesus would jesus
have to die on the cross well jesus
would have to die of course the
scriptures would be fulfilled no matter
what
but jesus would need to die because
we've all sinned and the penalty for sin
is death and he took the penalty of the
saved
so just like god
asked abraham to bring his son an
offerman abraham and isaac went
willingly to the place of sacrifice i'm
guessing that's just a theory again
christ would have
died it just would have been a willing
sacrifice as opposed to
something closer to a murder
so again when you start doing
hypotheticals it's all you can do is
kind of surmise
does that make sense robert
it makes sense i just thought it wasn't
i thought it was somebody who was kind
of indicated in the gospel not really
hypothetical but it doesn't make sense
though because
it it it was a blood sacrifice that uh
that needed to be uh answered if i'm
correct correct you're right yeah
without the only thing that covers our
sin it says without the shedding of
blood there is no forgiveness that's in
the scriptures so
um jesus would have had to shed his
blood for us to be forgiven
hey thank you so much
thank you pastors yeah thank you robert
next quarterback is charles listening in
virginia charles welcome to the program
charles i i think uh i got to press the
button there we go that's no it's let's
try that charles you there
yes can you hear me yeah we hear you we
we were hitting the wrong button sorry
yeah for a second i thought i'd have
myself used
all right
um i am a little nervous so please just
bear with me all right my i have a big
question about the ten commandments um
two whys and the how
um the exodus 20 account of the ten
commandments is what we usually go with
but
those stone tablets were destroyed and
moses had to go back up and in exodus 34
verse 10 to the end of the chapter we
can see a drastically different
content in those stone tablets of what
the commandments are so why do we go
with the
exodus 20 commandments and
why are they drastically different in
exodus 34
the new ones and how does the exodus 34
ones relate twice today if at all
well exodus 34 is not a list of the 10
commandments
exodus 34 is is in other words exodus 34
is not telling you what was written on
the stones because god told moses in the
beginning
he said to write the words that were on
the first table
so it wasn't a different it's not a
different set of commandments the lord
is continuing in exodus in exodus even
after the first ten commandments are
given in exodus 20 then god goes on
after exodus 20 he gives them other laws
ceremonial laws civil laws health laws
and he continues to do this here again
after exodus 34.
when he says you know you're not to make
molded gods for yourself that's not
reiterating the second commandment
he's
expanding on the ten commandments then
he talks about the firstborn son
and
you know he does re he mentions the
sabbath again
he talks about the annual feast but this
is not what was written on the second
table of stone they wrote the same thing
that was on the first set
you still there wow
yeah i'm just a little amazed it could
do you have the verse where it says that
um says that
yeah it's exodus 34 verse 1 and the lord
said to moses cut two tables of stone
like the first ones and i will write on
these tables the words that were on the
first tables you broke god is saying
it's going to be the same words that
were on the first tables
and then proof proof of that now if you
go to deuteronomy 5
you'll see the list here again
yeah deuteronomy 5 has the ten
commandments again
all right that's um awesome thank you
all right yeah yeah i'll keep it short
and simple yeah thank you it's the
question all right and uh that lesson we
offered earlier about written in stone
all right did we offer that one no not
yet just briefly yeah but we can
definitely
also answer this more for again the
study guide is called written in stone
and the number to call for that is
800-835-6747
and you can ask for that study guide
talking about the ten commandments and
we'll be happy to send that out to
anyone who calls and asks if you have a
bible question a phone line here to the
studio is
two nine 800-463-7297
next we have carlos listening in
california carlos welcome to the program
well hello pastors god bless you and uh
thank you for taking my call
my question is um i heard a rabbi on the
phone the other day stating that uh
isaac
was about 37 years old when he was being
offered to god
is that true
no i don't think so
um
because it tells us that his mother died
first of all if i'm not mistaken
um sarah bore isaac when she was 90 is
that right pastor ross abraham 100 and
she dies at 120
and so uh if isaac was 37 that would
have been uh after she died but it has
it has isaac being offered before she
dies
i think it's more likely that isaac was
about 17.
um when you look at the story before
the offering of isaac and i think that's
uh genesis 22
and afterward
um
yeah i i don't know why he said that
now it is interesting a guy that comes
online every day and he claims to be a
rabbi and uh
well that's i i i needed to ask and
thank you very much
and let me tell you
carlos there is a website amazingfacts
has we haven't mentioned lately but i
tried it again this week it's working
great it's called bible timeline or
biblehistory.com
if you type in
you can look at the bible ages and dates
of all these
main characters and you just slide the
little slider across it'll tell you
how long isaac lived it'll tell you when
the main events happened in his life and
i think it even talks about the
sacrifice of isaac or the offering of
isaac
in that timeline it'll tell you how old
he was there thank you for your question
all right we've got um zach listening
from north carolina zach welcome to the
program
it's an honor for me for having to speak
with you guys
um
thank you question also related to the
sabbath
um
i'm a member of a
church
and
they
a lot of the members there asked me
about why i don't come in
um
every sabbath
and
um my main answer is the pandemic
so my main question is what does the
bible have to say about
um worshiping
at a physical church
every sabbath okay
and so the the idea here of course is
importance of gathering together to
worship on the sabbath day
i think we need to be practical you know
if there's a pandemic rampaging through
the country and we know that we can be
safer and it's temporary by staying home
there's no sin and staying home because
of sickness it's always true that if
you're sick it's a good idea to stay
home whether there's a pandemic or not
and so you know for
a time to preserve health
but i think as a principle you know once
that the major risk is gone
in hebrews chapter 10 it says let us not
forsake the assembling of ourselves
together as the manner of some is so
it's very important for us not to
forsake certainly not permanently and
then you can also read the part of
keeping the sabbath you read there in
leviticus 23 it calls the sabbath a holy
convocation that means
a convening a time for us to come
together and then the example you have
in the new testament with the apostles
and jesus his custom was he went into
the temple or synagogue on the sabbath
day
the apostles went from
church to church on the sabbath day
uh so it's important for us to get
together and
you know gain strength now like i said
that doesn't mean there it's uh it's a
sin if during a time of pandemic people
are you know going through some
temporary health crisis
but there's always going to be risk for
god's people coming together we're not
done friends we'll be back with more
bible questions right after this
important break
[Music]
stay tuned bible answers live will
return shortly
[Music]
amazing facts offer some of the best
christian resources for all ages we hope
our products will enrich your life and
your walk with the lord
if you liked the final events of bible
prophecy dvd you'll love the new final
event sharing magazine read gripping
content in this visually rich resource
and share it with others
get yours today by calling
800-538-7275 or visit afbookstore.com
can't get enough amazing facts bible
study you don't have to wait until next
week to enjoy more truth-filled
programming
visit the amazing facts media library at
aftv.org
at
aftv.org you can enjoy video and audio
presentations as well as printed
material all free of charge 24 hours a
day seven days a week right from your
computer or mobile device visit aftv.org
do you feel as though your world is
spiraling out of control
our economic uncertainty and an unknown
future leaving you with unsettled
feelings about the future
or perhaps new life challenges are
frightening you more than they should
are you sinking while you're thinking
excessive worry can consume you eating
you from the inside out resulting in
sickness insomnia and paralyzing fear it
can also damage relationships ruin
opportunities and yes diminish your
witness for the gospel but problems are
an everyday part of life so how can we
better manage the worry that comes with
them
worry affects everybody differently but
it's all driven by fear
so how can you overcome a world full of
reasons to be anxious
i'd like to recommend for you my new
book finding peace in a world of worry
it's packed with inspiring information
and useful solutions
to not only liberate you from stress
but also to prevent stress from building
up in the first place
best of all
these principles all come directly from
the word of god
you'll discover a lifeline to victory a
place where you can cast your cares upon
christ and experience a serenity that
isn't subject to your circumstances get
your copy of pastor doug's finding peace
in a world of worry today call
800-538-7275
or visit afbookstore.com
you're listening to bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of god and his plan to
save you so what are you waiting for get
practical answers about the good book
for a better life today
if you have a question about the bible
or living the christian life call us now
at 800 god says that's 800-463-7297
now let's rejoin our hosts for more
bible answers live
hello listening friends welcome back to
bible answers live if you tuned in along
the way we are a live international
interactive bible study
and we're going to go back to our phones
in just a moment my name is doug
batchelor my name is john ross and we're
going to go to our next caller pass
today we've got ron listening in canada
ron welcome to the program you on the
air
hey good night pastor ross good night
pastor bachelor very glad to be on for
the first time i got a quick question
um who are the two um anointed ones in
zechariah 4 14. my wife was and i was
we're doing our devotion tonight and we
were reading and was like whoa what is
that
yeah this would be the same as the two
witnesses that you find in revelation
chapter 11 you'll find it says
they're the two olive branches
that are before the throne of god
we believe that this represents the word
of god
uh because the word of god of course is
uh enhanced by the holy spirit that's
talking about the olive oil
and um
when you think about uh when it talks
about two anointed ones
the mouth says and the bible says in the
mouth of two or three witnesses let
everything be established the bible is
compared to a sword with two edges
it talks about the law and the prophets
two characteristics of god's church in
revelation chapter
12 it says she keeps the commandments of
god and that's the testimony of jesus
the spirit of prophecy
and so you've got the law and the
prophets it's like moses and elijah
moses was the law
elijah was the prophets and moses and
elijah appear to endorse the ministry of
jesus
in mark chapter 9 i think also in luke
chapter 9 and in matthew you find that
story all three places so
it's talking about the word of god going
through all of the earth
and you find more about this again in
revelation chapter 11 and i think pastor
ross we've got a book on the two
witnesses
that's right
i was just looking the book up yes and
again if you'd like to learn more about
that just call 800-835-67
and you can ask for the book on the two
witnesses and we'll be happy to send
that out to anyone who is in north
america outside of north america you can
still read the book but you need to go
to the amazing facts website just
amazingfacts.com
thanks for your call uh ron we got elvis
listening in new york elvis welcome to
the program
hey how's it going um i'm glad i'm glad
to be here it's my first time a fairly
new christian here 23 years old
so you know i get confused a lot and
i've never been to church but uh anyways
i was
i was debating with some friends about
the topic of hell and they were telling
me and i've learned through through you
guys that hell is not eternal conscious
torment and also that nobody is in a in
hell right now so i was
debating and they pointed me to
revelation 20
verse 13 and 14.
uh should i go ahead and read that
go ahead sir yeah all right it says and
the sea gave up the dead that were in it
and death and hades delivered up the
dead who are in them and they were
judged each one according to his works
then death and hades were cast into the
lake of fire this is the second death
and anyone not found written in the book
of life was cast into the lake of fire
so yeah we have no
no contest or disagreement with any
scripture and this is very clear that
there is a judgment at the end nobody's
burning in hell now because the judgment
hasn't happened yet jesus said the
judgment is the last day
and so
um
there's going to be a time when the
wicked are cast into the lake of fire
and it says death in hell even the grave
is going to be burnt up
you know pastor just add to that i think
some confusion is it talks about death
and hades in in the king james another
word for that word in the original greek
just simply means the grave
so death and the grave it's not a place
of torment it just means the grave in
the greek yeah so god is going to
he's going to abolish anything going in
the lake of fire is abolished
and god is going to abolish death
there'll be no more death no more
weeping no more funerals
and
nothing here that says that uh there is
a lake of fire burning now or that it
burns eternally
yeah yeah that's what they were telling
me i don't know but yeah thank you
that's it yeah no we have a a good study
guide on that we'll send you uh if you'd
like a free copy or anyone out there and
it's not what pastor ross and i teach
these are just scriptures and we'll be
happy to share that with you and it's
called is the devil in charge of hell
and the number to call for that is eight
hundred eight three five six seven four
seven it's one of our amazing facts
study guides it's called is the devil in
charge of hell of course we'll send that
to anyone who calls and asks or as
mentioned earlier you can read it online
at the amazing facts website thanks for
calling elvis we have janice listening
in tennessee janice welcome to the
program
thank you very much i really enjoy your
program it's very wonderful
and thank you for taking my call
appreciate it thanks for calling okay
um i was wondering about uh genesis 3 16
it's talking about when eve ate the
fruit and disobeyed god
and he talked and it's saying how the
negative part you know the sad part of
sin
for a woman
where it says i will greatly multiply
your sorrow and your conception and in
pain you shall bring forth children your
desire shall be for your husband and he
shall rule over you
does that mean your desire can be since
it's negative things here does that mean
you could have too much desire for your
husband
you know this is an interesting
i don't think it means that
uh i i think that um
this is a place where um
it's hinting in the hebrew that your
desire would be to have dominion over
your husband and then god is answering
that he's saying but he shall rule over
you meaning that the leadership in the
family should be coming from the man
and so he the last statement there in
verse 16 is actually dealing with the
verse immediately before
that
you may have a desire to dominate but
you should be submissive i don't know
what your take is on that pastor ross
yeah that's the way i i've understood it
as and i'm not a hebrew scholar but when
i read the commentaries that's what they
seem to indicate
um
so yeah it's i don't think it's saying
that there would be an an over
um
an over desire for your husband that
needs to be mitigated
okay okay that that helps thank you very
much all right thank you so much
all right we've got uh robert listening
from north carolina robert welcome to
the program
good evening uh doug and john pastor
both of you i
this is my first time
but i have a question of how i would
answer verse 19
of
matthew 16.
the matthew 16 and
verses 18 and 19 is talking about
jesus is talking to peter about building
his church on the rock
of course i believe all that but i'd
like to know if someone questioned me
how would i answer
the follow-up in 19. all right let me
read this for our friends that are
listening robert we're always mindful
that a lot of people are listening on a
radio and they're driving they can't
look it up
and jesus says i say unto you that peter
you are
well let me back up you almost need to
read the previous verse
where jesus says you know who do you say
that i am and peter is the one in verse
16 who declares you are the christ the
son of the living god
jesus said blessed are you simon barjona
flesh and blood did not reveal this to
you but my father who is in heaven and
christ is continuing and i say to you
you are peter now that word there peter
is petros
in the greek petros is a stone that
might roll around in a creek or on the
beach you could pick it up and skip it
and throw it
and he says you are petros and on this
rock
and the word rock there is petra
i will build my church now people think
well does that mean that jesus built the
church on peter
oh that'd be kind of frightening because
if you look down just a few verses
jesus turns to peter in verse 23 and
says get behind me satan
so here peter says something that his
spirit led in one verse and then he says
something that is demon-led a few verses
later and so the church is not built on
peter peter was very unstable
jesus saying the church is being built
on the rock
that
peter had declared that christ is the
messiah that's the rock of truth that is
the cornerstone
of the gospel the word petra is talking
about a rock of immense proportions on
this rock i will build my church peter
says you are peter you're a rolling
stone
that's petros but on this petra of what
you've declared that i am the messiah i
will build my church on that truth
so
hopefully that helps a little bit robert
and we we do appreciate your question a
lot of people wonder about that first
you know it's also interesting pastor if
you look at some of the other writings
of peter for example in first peter
chapter 2 verse 4 peter says clearly
that jesus is
that living rock upon which the church
is based and he's the cornerstone the
foundation of the church so there was no
confusion in peter's mind as to who the
foundation of the church is it's clearly
christ and he brings that out thank you
for your call robert we've got uh
colleen listening in florida colleen
welcome to the program
all right good evening pastors thank you
so much for taking my call
my question is in reference to second
samuel 24
and first chronicles 21 verses 13 to 14.
in the first scott when god was sending
david's options for his disobedience
in second samuels it means it says seven
years
of his famine
however in first chronicles it says
three years of the famine
yeah and also
it says the threshing flow is a rune of
the jebusite
in ii samuel but in first chronicles it
says the threatening fourth ornament the
jebusite
all right on the second question those
names are the same
um keep in mind they they didn't have
the same spelling alphabet that we use
and when you translate from
hebrew and aramaic to greek
and then now to english
folks are sometimes wondering what
letters to use for people to
articulate pronunciation
but it's the same person this is the
jebusite who owned the property on mount
moriah he had the threshing floor there
and david wanted to buy that to offer to
the lord that later became the place
where the temple was built on mount
moriah and it's still there today where
the dome of the rock is that was the
threshing floor of ornan according to ii
samuel
the better question you're asking is why
does it say that nathan the prophet
offered seven years of famine in one
place and three years of famine in
another you know the best answer i think
i can give you is
uh the bible is inspired but sometimes
the copyists and the translations are
not
and as you go from one copy to another
sometimes there may have been a number
that was missed they'll you know they
look at it and there's very little
difference
i'll give you a quick example
i was a hooligan when i was a kid and so
i wanted to buy alcohol though i was too
young i was born in 1957
i took my driver's permit when i was
i think is only 14
and i took the seven and turned it into
a two
it's very easy to do small little line
and it worked for years
and uh sometimes one little tittle
changes the number and it's probably
that the manuscript that they were
reading the seven and the two it was
hard to determine so those who
translated from uh second chronicles
they saw that as a two and another one
saw it as a seven or three rather
so
yeah there are some minor things like
that in the bible that are conundrums
you know it's interesting in the uh
septuagint which is the greek
translation of the hebrew old testament
which was in existence the time of
christ
they translate the seven years as three
years here in uh second samuel oh so
they do the sun there's no conflict no
conflict in the septuagint well that's a
good point oh there you go it's both
three months so
three years three years yeah
all right thanks for your call the next
quarter that we have is melissa
listening from california melissa
welcome to the program
hi thank the lord you guys answered oh
yeah well thanks for calling we're
thanking the lord you called
okay
so i'm a little stumped on
luke chapter 5.
um jesus is demonstrating to his
disciples
the ministry and the path of it but
before the parable is introduced from
verse 6 to 39 he refers to um
fasting with them and then he says
then they will fast
um in those days when they're taken away
and then the parable goes on if you want
to read it for the callers i'm assuming
and i i don't want to assume that's what
i'm calling that they're referring it's
referring to sin itself
well let me read this it says
jesus said in verse 36 and this is luke
chapter 5
he said no one puts a piece of new
garment on an old one otherwise the new
makes a tear and also the piece that was
taken out of the new garment does not
match the old and no one puts wine
no one puts new wine and old wine skins
or else a new wine will burst the wine
skins and be spilled and the wine skins
will be ruined but new wine must be put
into new wineskins and both are
preserved and no one having drunk old
wine immediately desires new for he says
the old is better christ is talking
about that
people were going to struggle with
change
he had come to bring the new wine by the
way which is unfermented of the gospel
but a lot of the religious leaders have
become intoxicated by their traditions
and he said you know i'm going to have
to put the new wine in new wineskins
meeting the apostles he didn't go to
the scribes and the pharisees and the
priests they were settled in their ways
they would not listen
he went to
shepherds and fishermen and tax
collectors
and he put the new truth the fresh truth
in them and they were they were ready uh
ready to receive it
you know it's also interesting we got
the the
in the first part of the parable new
garment nobody puts a a new piece of
cloth on an old garment well in the
bible garments often have to do or a
symbol of righteousness and you had the
pharisees who prided themselves in their
own righteousness and they rejected the
righteousness that jesus came to give
and they of course claimed their own
doctrine and they didn't want to receive
the new wine or the doctrine or the
teaching of christ so really jesus is
addressing something that
other disciples were aware of why didn't
the pharisees accept jesus why didn't
they accept his teaching well because
they were clinging to their old ways and
they didn't want to receive the new the
gospel that jesus came to give
very good okay
thank you melissa good question hope
that helps a little
yes it does just um one more comment
that kind of explains um for
i guess the church itself it's
they kind of implement things in various
churches um may
because of their
ideas right yeah sometimes it's
tradition and they're not going by the
scriptures yeah
yeah absolutely amen thank you
thank you good night
next quarter that we have is uh edly
listening from canada adley welcome to
the program
thank you this is my first time um
so my question is um
why did god choose mary to be jesus's
um
mommy
okay thank you adland it says in our
notes here at least five years old love
to hear the young people calling in with
their bible questions um
well we believe that the lord chose mary
because he knew in her heart that she
was sincere that she wanted to serve god
and that she was
she had faith
and she had lived a life where um she
was dedicated to god and so the lord was
looking for a young lady who could be
the mother who would raise jesus
with devotion with love that would teach
him the bible that would be a good
example that would be a good mother
watch over him and protect him and mary
had those characteristics and god chose
her for that and so a wonderful
opportunity and a great responsibility
thank you for your call hadley
next quarter that we have is uh tavion
listening from illinois tavian welcome
to the program
hey you got it right this time all right
we're learning
no but um my question is is that is it
okay
so like for the promises of god and
essentially for what i'm understanding
by faith you know after years of being a
christian
is it okay for me to claim something
even though i haven't received it yet or
i don't feel it
well yeah in some cases if if you've met
the criteria of a bible promise then
believe
you know for example just start with
salvation
when
if you repent of your sins
and you confess your sins
the bible says if we confess our sins he
is faithful this is first john chapter
nine
chapter one verse nine he is faithful
and just to forgive us our sins and to
cleanse us from all unrighteousness
don't wait until you feel like your
cleanse
believe it thank him for forgiving you
and you will feel better because of your
faith
so there are cases where god makes a
promise
and he says you know for instance god
says you know fear not i'm with you well
you may not feel like he's with you you
may not see him with you but you can
claim the promise that he said he's with
you believe it by faith
and you'll feel better
you know the bible says that the
righteous walk by faith not by sight
it's claiming the promises of god and
just holding on to them and like you say
the feelings come later but they don't
always uh come first
that comes first yeah now just let me
add to this because
some people will misunderstand the faith
in action
and you know i've heard preachers say
and just claim god that you're going to
have the money to pay for that new house
you're buying and so a person says i
just believe that god wants to bless me
and he's going to help me buy that new
house and i'm going to put down the down
payment even though i don't have a job
yet i'm going to trust that
and they get into debt they're kind of
being presumptuous that's called
tempting the lord so you know there's
there's a delicate balance between
claiming the promises of god and having
faith and stepping out in faith
and you want to be careful not to abuse
the promises of god and be presumptuous
or tempt the lord so i don't know if if
that helps answer what you're saying
tavon
i know it does
alrighty thank you so much appreciate
your call
we've got lance listening in texas lance
welcome to the program
hi
nice to meet you guys
thanks for calling
and your question um yes
so um
yeah so if a married couple
divorced with no biblical reason and
they marry again
um
[Music]
are they gonna be living in a constant
eternal state of sin
and uh my second question related to
that is it i mean easy
if that's if that's the case should they
be worse and remain single forever
yeah it's a good and it's a practical
question sometimes people have what you
would call irreconcilable differences
nobody has committed adultery you know
the biblical grounds for divorce as if
there's fornication or unfaithfulness
and uh there may be a couple and they
just say oh man we just can't handle
this anymore and they separate they
don't have biblical grounds then are
they free to remarry according to the
bible they're not free to remarry
paul even says you might be better to
remain single now if one partner and
this is often to be honest sometimes
they play the waiting game and they wait
for the other one
to
get married again they say well now
they've broken the wedding vows now i
can get married
and that's not the right attitude so
then you have a third question embedded
in your question
and that is are they living in perpetual
sin well i know a lot of people that
maybe have gotten divorced and remarried
and they do not have biblical grounds
but then they later go through a real
conversion
an example would be king david king
david definitely did not have biblical
grounds for taking bathsheba and killing
her husband
but after david thoroughly repented and
they actually i mean they suffered he
lost the baby and a son and lost actual
several sons because of his sin
the bible says david comforted his wife
god refers to bathsheba as david's wife
solomon then later comes through
bathsheba and so does jesus so he
ultimately forgave her he forgave the
woman
in who
was at the well who had had five
husbands and when abraham had an affair
with hagar or you know had a concubine
she was sent away and
sarah was his wife and so
you know sometimes we we scramble the
eggs and you can't unscramble them but
it doesn't mean that this is the
unpardonable sin but i don't want to
leave people with the impression that
they can just get married and divorced
and married and divorced
the bible is clear that that is a sin
and it hurts families it hurts people it
hurts society you know we do have a book
pass today dealing with the subjects
called marriage divorce and remarriage
and we'll be happy to send this to
anyone who wants to learn more about
what does the bible say on the subject
of marriage the number for that is
800-835-6747 that has a resource phone
line and you can ask for the book it's
called marriage divorce and remarriage
we'll be happy to send it to anyone in
north america
thanks for call lance we got uh
claudette listening from new jersey
claudette welcome to the program
hello good evening evening
thank you for taking my call
yeah and your question tonight
yes this is my first time calling i
would like you to explain for me
why
the lord's prayer in matthew chapter 6
verses 9 to 13
is different
from the one in luke
chapter 11
verse 2 to 4. and the second part of my
question is
in in verse 4 it ends but deliver us
from evil
while in matthew it ends with
um
verse 13 for this is a kingdom
and the power and the glory forever amen
all right claudette good question let's
let's talk about that when the lord
gives the uh what we call the lord's
prayer it's actually not the lord's
prayer if you want to know the lord's
prayer that's probably john chapter 17.
it's actually a prayer for the disciples
and he says when you pray pray in this
manner now when you read it in matthew
and that would be in matthew chapter 6
verse 9 it says when you pray pray in
this manner jesus probably repeated this
more than one time and told them that
this is a pattern for prayer meaning
you don't have to say it exactly the
same way their points and their
principles and what i love
about the lord's prayers you've actually
got seven petitions that you find there
in the lord's prayer
and it's kind of divided up like the ten
commandments where you get the first 40
percent deal with our relationship with
god
the last 60 deals with our relationship
with each other
talks about
it says thy name thy kingdom thy will
are the first three petitions
and then you've got uh you know give us
forgive us
lead us deliver us
in the later petitions
and so um
it's it's divided up by you know same
way as the ten commandments so same
principle so claudette i think that
jesus said the lord's prayer to the
disciples more than one time as he went
from town to town and he would teach
people how to pray sometimes he tells
his parables with a little different
spin you'll see that hey listening
friends thank you i don't think we have
time to take another call but we do want
to remind you that amazing facts is
something you can listen to all week
long by going to the website or you can
go to the amazing facts tv channel
that's
aftv.org
thank you for keeping the program on the
air you can go to the website and donate
and we'll be back in a moment with some
rapid fire questions
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
bible even better than before
bible answers live is produced by
amazing facts international a
faith-based ministry located in granite
bay california
hello friends welcome back to bible
answers live for those of you who stayed
by we took a little break because of our
friends on satellite radio there to
close the program just a little earlier
we want to thank you for your many
questions that you've emailed to us and
passed today we're going to try and
answer as many of these questions as we
can in the next two minutes or so so
here's the first one the question is
when will armageddon occur
well armageddon of course it's in the
future it's not a battle between china
and russia and people are paying a lot
of attention to russia right now and
israel or anything like that now
armageddon it says is when the dragon
makes war against the woman and you see
jesus coming in revelation 19
uh conquering and to deliver his bride
so the first part of armageddon begins
then the ultimate part of armageddon is
at the end of the 1000 years when god
totally defeats the enemies of his
people
okay another question that we have how
long was the time frame of the ten
plagues of egypt
the bible doesn't tell us specifically
the dates of months or weeks or days but
based on the context it seems like the
plagues come back to back rather quickly
something like the trials that came to
job it seems like they came one right
after another and so
we think it was probably a matter of
months probably all of it happened
somewhere in the span of about
45 days or so
okay another question is in hebrews
chapter 1 verse 4 speaking of jesus that
says haven't been made better than
angels can you explain
yeah well christ of course is uh he is
the angel maker
because you know he made all things that
may have been made but
he also
became a man but after his resurrection
he is higher than the angels because the
angels worship him
and so the only one we're supposed to
worship is god so that's why it's saying
jesus is not just a man he's better than
the angels because the angels worship
him okay uh next question is uh is the
elijah message the same as the three
angels messages of revelation 14
well the final elijah message it's
talking about a message that brings the
church to revival
is going to be done during the same time
as the three angels message but it's
more of a message of calling people to
return to god whereas the three angels
message is more specifically warning
people about the coming judgment coming
out of babylon the mark of the beast and
the coming of christ
okay well pastor that's probably it for
all of our questions for this evening
just a reminder friends if you have a
question you can email it to us at bal
questions amazing facts
thank you listening friends as i
mentioned before if you want to support
the program just simply go to
amazingfacts.org
and click the donate but help us share
the truth with others
you